do you remember this diagram from lesson
one the adapter has a reference to the
raw data and it has instructions on how
to build each list item layout these
layouts eventually make it into the
ListView here but what happens if any of
this data changes let's say for example
there's a fourth contact named Don
the adapter knows how to create a list
item layout for Don
but now the ListView is outdated because
it only has three items somehow we need
the adapter to notify the ListView that
things have changed and lucky for us
there's a method called adapter notify
data set changed this notified any
attached observers like this one that
the underlying adapter data has changed
then the ListView needs to populate its
children again so acid after how many
items there are and adapter responds
with for then the ListView goes and
fetches each one individually until it
fills up the screen and it's through
that method that the ListView is able to
get all its list items but now you must
be thinking how did we actually update
the ListView successfully without adding
the sign of code in our app well with
array adapter whenever you add or remove
elements from it it internally calls
notify data set changed that means we
don't have to do anything but how can we
confirm this well we can check the
actual implementation of the array
adapter class in the framework and
here's the code for the array adapter
class within the android framework you
can follow along with the link below
first we're going to search for the add
method remember we added forecasts
strings to the adapter using this method
and sure enough we see that the notify
data set changed method is called
internally but you might be thinking
what about this boolean here well let's
look it up if you scroll to the top you
see that notify on change is declared as
true initially as you go through through
other references you see that it's only
changed here in this set notify on
change method since we don't call this
public method with the value false then
we know that we're going to be safely
notified each time the adapter updates
now let's go back to the add method I
want to show you one more thing
you'll notice that in the at all method
it only notifies its observers once
whereas in the ad method every time you
call this it will update its observers
that means that our code actually is
refreshing the list every time so if
you're targeting honeycomb above you can
use this method to be a little more
efficient in general don't be afraid to
try to do this on your own as a general
pro tip if you're ever unsure about
something feel free to go and check the
Android source code don't treat the
framework code like a black box take
advantage of the fact that Android is
open-source the more you learn about the
platform the better of an Android
developer you can become